First, they brought you sly. Then they gross you out.
Now. Nickelodeon brings you their crowning achievement,
the best appropriation of Asian culture since ghost dog, way of the samurai.
Avatar.
The last Airbender experience, the show that everyone loves.
And since it's been on Netflix, no one will shut up about
[inaudible] Full of bright colors,
silly jokes and simple life lessons that will delight your inner eight year old
because the show was made for actual eight year olds.
[Inaudible].
But who cares? I get my first born. If it meant we get a season four,
why didn't they make a season four anyway,
[inaudible] And to real-world a four kingdoms each with its own stereotype.
I mean, personality type, I mean element solid earth, flighty,
air, soothing water, and fiery fire.
Where warriors known as vendors can fling stuff around by doing karate next to
it. Masters of martial arts can turn their bodies and delivering weapons
and every animal had sex with every other animal.
Giant eel gradual baby saber tooth mousse lion Cub.
Love is love is love is best not to think too hard about it.
Everything changed when the fire nation attack 100 years ago and then
nothing changed for like 95 years because neither side is making progress.
Now only the avatar can end the Spire Fest once and for all a
and elongated baby with a downvote on his head.
He's a kid struggling with air attention deficit disorder.
Remember the reason we're here. All right, time to practice water bands.
Screws around all year, then freaks out the week before finals,
four days rounding out the EBIDTA teens is guitarra a moon powered Reiki, and.
I can feel a lot of energy twisted up around there.
Toth a barefoot blind bad-ass straight out of a Tarantino movie.
Sorry, shoes.
Soka. A men's rights activist.
Guys are better at hunting and fighting and stuff like that.
It's just the natural order of things.
Who over the course of the series has the massage money literally beaten out of
him in a performance. So nice. He's doing it twice.
Something so strangely familiar boomerang.
No shade here. Get that soccer money, bro. And upper.
The only reason any of them are still alive.
[Inaudible] how dare you. Blame opera. He saved your life three times today.
The heroes is a family of villains who map perfectly onto the target Ariens and
the Lannisters leading the charge of these twisted Firestarters is Sukkot and
outcast. Prince made a fire and [inaudible].
It keep exploding in my face. Like everything always.
Does. Whose one purpose in life is to count,
need to capture the avatar is to capture the idea.
The avatar is far more important.
This cowards a hundred years in hiding are over and I want the avatar I'm
chasing the avatar. Where's the avatar S standing view.
The only view I'm interested in seeing is the avatar chains.
Oh, we get it already. I didn't.
Capture the avatar. Who cares.
By his side is the big Lebowski of the fire nation general.
Ayro a magical uncle on the hunt for some TNA.
Sharing tea with a fascinating stranger is one of life's
true delights.
Your beauty's intoxicating or more key please.
In case someone brings home a lady friend,
this is the best tea in the city. The secret ingredient is love.
I didn't see you get hit with the tongue.
These two will carry the emotional and dramatic weight of the series with
satisfying character arcs that will bring tears of joy and sadness to your eyes.
And then there's the other two they're just mean,
do you like overarching stories or are you more of an episodic plot person to
that avatar answers? Yes. As the show balances,
serving the main quest with a weekly dose of villages that need help villages
that get burned down because they helped Saka complaining.
Dumb, ugly vine guitar, getting preachy.
It's not like I'm a preachy cry baby.
You can't resist giving over emotional speeches about hope all the time.
I know sometimes it hurts more to home and it hurts more to care,
but you have to promise me that you won't stop caring.
Searching for a teacher to help him master the elements.
Even though what he really needs is a master to help with his blood sugar
issues.
Sorry, we got your back. Thanks.
Navigant agent breakfast before you fight the fire Lord.
So celebrate the show that challenged kids with difficult things.
Duty calls you to sacrifice your own spiritual needs.
In between all the goofy sound effects.
That's probably the closest thing we have to a successor to star Wars and that
the original is beloved, but nitpicked and the SQL a bunch of people off. Oh,
well at least no one will ever try to make a live action adaptation ever again.
Why must we fly so close to the sun story?
The nature boy. Whoa. This is Kotara.
She's got my back. Okay. Boomerang Bay fond footballing phone pong,
pyro red spill the tea. Kiyoshi
[inaudible] come out and play. Hey Kat bus swiper.
No swiping. Stop trying to make fetch happen. Tylee blah, blah,
blah.
I'd like to take his face off female cost players at Comicon
Chan and Ron. John. No joke here. Just a big fan. Netflix synergy.
It's just a river of lava. Hey phase,
we don't care about the rules and we're not asking.
It's time to did it. Did it dual.
Your final test is Andrew.
And let this be the end of this rivalry.
I'll be outside if you're man enough to fight me, stand on, fight avatar. Oh,
where are we fighting? Do you really want to fight me?
I really do do each other.
I order you to fight an Agni Chi, but
spirits, dog,
spirit magic. Doesn't work that way. Soccer. It's more like
[inaudible] first base. What if we kissed us kissing?
I donate you too.
And death cabbage for QD.
[Inaudible]
Oh, forget it.
Earth, wind and fire
Nan. The show is okay,
but I think they should've gone with the original four elements.
Smoke, slime, fire and stink,
never underestimate the power of stink.
Have you mastered the elements of avatar the last Airbender than you should play
our air bending condition of the fandom five,
the trivia game where you can win up to $650.
That's a lot of cabbage click the box or the link in the description.
Fire Lord OSI.
You have devastated the balance of this world and now you shall pay the ultimate
price.